why is storytelling important to you
i guess i feel like some degree it's um
a service um not like a
like a car repair service but you're
you are in service to storytelling
whether it's
you know nobody starts and makes money
so or few people do so
if you're telling stories then it's
because
you want to like you would
you're spending time with these
characters and building this world
without most of the time without anyone
watching without anyone
seeing and so you're
alone with it but you're making it to
give
to other people so it's a service
you are at the service of the reader
the audience the is experiencing
whatever you're making and whatever
medium
or media as a case would be
[Music]
so i guess it's important to me because
i feel like i'm
[Music]
helping a little bit um
for what what do you have stories gives
people somewhere to go away from all
this
from to suspend their disbelief to go
hang out with a
hitman who's a vampire and drive around
and kill some people
that is an escape for people it is
somewhere to go it is suspension of
disbelief
stories have been around since the
beginning of time because
that's what we all sat around and did
because it was really shitty wi-fi when
you're a caveman and
so people were telling stories and
drawing stuff and and
then it's you know then it's just verbal
then it's just
one generation telling the next
generation telling the next generation
until you start writing that stuff down
so i and and stories are
man you can get people killed with
stories you can
change people's lives with stories you
can
a whole country can believe a story and
and do really bad things
and have been done yeah yeah
storytelling is
is really powerful that suspension of
disbelief thing
the real world uses it all the time
it's not just for storytellers
what about if a writer says storytelling
for me is a selfish uh
motive it's a selfish endeavor and i
make no apologies for it
i love creating other worlds it doesn't
even mean i need people to love the
story i just love to be
yeah that it's that sounds fantastic but
that storytellers the whole not needing
any one thing
is then no one's gonna see your man
you're you're just gonna type in just
like i'm just gonna fill up hard drives
with stories because i
love it so much and i'm so great really
are you just waiting until you die and
then someone's going to publish all your
stuff
and now i
i think that person's if
maybe if that's what it takes for them
to be able to write
great but the reality is if no one sees
it then
you know like screenplays are maps for
movies they're not meant to be read
they're meant to be made so all the
movies that i have written so far
have not been made and will not be made
and that's okay that's some of them are
shitty
a couple of them i'm probably going to
adapt into books
because they were fun to write then and
they would be
i think more fun as a book and i
wouldn't have to deal with trying to get
it done
um and also if i was to make a movie it
would be indie
and i know what it's like to be crushed
by production
i would never make a movie at this point
just because i can't do anything else
when i'm making a movie
i know people have made movies it's two
years
pretty much at least all the time full
time
and and it's really expensive
and it takes a lot of people and it
takes a lot of people
who have to stay with the project
it's really hard to keep people
motivated when
they're not making a lot of money and
most likely i'm making a movie where
they're not making a lot of money
and then after i have that movie made
then i have to get people to watch it
and all of that seems like
too much to do
[Music]
for me for the amount of time i've got
left on the planet
and for what else i think i could
achieve in the
same amount of time
[Music]
and also i could make a shitty movie so
i'd hate to spend two years making
you